the return of mjolnir jane foster and
the birth of mighty thor the trailers
for the fourth thor movie seemed to give
a lot away but you have no idea how much
about the movie they were really hiding
warning spoilers ahead for thor love and
thunder thor love and thunder brings
chris hemsworth's asgardian hero back to
the big screen for his fourth solo movie
which sees him struggling to stop gore
the god butcher from slaughtering all
the deities throughout the universe in
case his name didn't make it clear
enough gore the god butcher is out for
revenge on the gods after the death of
his family which he blames on his own
deities who didn't step in to help
thankfully thor isn't alone on his quest
to save the various pantheons he has
rookie hero and ex-girlfriend jane
foster along to help and distract him in
equal measure although thor's hammer
mjolnir was destroyed by hella in thor
ragnarok the object has been
mysteriously reassembled and deems jane
worthy enough to wield the powers of
thor the first trailers for the 2022
sequel teased the heroic transformation
as well as thor's shock over her
newfound abilities but the footage never
reveals how the iconic hammer gets
reforged it's quite simple really it
calls to her and reassembles on its own
because thor asked it to always protect
her in a flashback and she proves worthy
enough to wield it during a press
conference for the movie director taika
waititi teased that mjolnir's return
leads to a surprising love triangle the
filmmaker said of thor's dilemma look
it's hard to see the ex-girlfriend turns
up dressed as him that's a shock and all
the sudden the weapon that he held so
dear and so on for so many years now
belongs to someone else and then he has
stormbreaker who starts to sense a
little jealousy there you know this
isn't the only time the love and thunder
trailers lied to us about the god of
thunder's fourth solo outing either if
you only saw the trailers you might
assume love and thunder is a movie
primarily about thor teaming up with the
guardians of the galaxy to fight a bunch
of alien marauders this would make sense
given that he leaves new asgard with the
gang at the end of avengers end game but
the film's opening montage hilariously
narrated by korg reveals that thor's
adventures with the guardians only
reminds him that he feels empty inside
largely because of his breakup with jane
so after saving a peaceful race of blue
aliens from a furry band of raiders thor
and korg part ways with the guardians
that's right if you were looking for the
next chapter of the guardian story
you'll have to wait for james gunn's
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 because
this ain't it it's a little
disappointing since there was plenty of
chatter about the cosmic heroes
returning for the thor sequel with fans
understandably expecting them to have a
sizeable role simply because of the time
and effort it takes to get the ensemble
cast in for filming unfortunately once
thor starts hunting gore the guardians
don't appear at all in the rest of the
film it's a shame but this is thor and
jane's story and it's probably for the
best that all the big personalities on
peter quill's crew don't take it over
the trailers also don't touch on jane
having cancer at all instead they just
show us that she has thor's powers and
fight scenes set in new asgard and
omnipotent city and her wicked asgardian
costume to boot it's obvious why marvel
studios kept this out of the marketing
because her poor health is a key
emotional plot point to the story as
well as being a drastic development for
jane's arc the movie wastes no time in
explaining that jane has stage 4 cancer
and that she's going through
chemotherapy let's not forget that
portman actually clarified that the film
uses the storyline and jason aaron's
mighty thor comics back in 2020 in an
interview with yahoo so it's not like it
was a secret just something that didn't
need to be in the trailers the star
vaguely touched on the cancer storyline
when speaking to variety recently saying
that the duality of being a hero might
give someone a different perspective on
their human life taika ytt added part of
why natalie wanted to play that
character is that she has a dilemma in
the book
the health element obviously affects how
jane acts as mighty thor while also
changing thor's perspective on the
universe plus using her cancer in the
marketing would definitely feel grim
placing this plot element at odds with
the light exciting tone the trailers
tried to convey in the final battle with
gore jane decides to become mighty thor
for a final time to stop him from
killing all the gods using the eternity
altar although gore makes it to eternity
jane's sacrifice and thor's decision to
be with her in her final moments makes
the villain change his mind about what
to do with the universe so basically
it's a good thing marvel didn't include
jane's health in the trailers even if it
was a bit deceptive the trailers also
did a grand job of hiding christian
bale's gore aside from a few moody shots
of him snarling threats to the gods as
he wields the necro sword to be fair
with a name like gore the god butcher it
doesn't take a genius to figure out what
his goals are in the sequel so marvel
didn't need to explicitly reveal his
full plan but what is a complete
surprise is the fact that he kidnaps all
the children from new asgard as a way of
luring thor and mighty thor into the
necroverse the gambit works as expected
in the film which means he can focus on
his true goal to steal thor's
stormbreaker acts this is all so he can
get to the altar of eternity a place
which would let him resurrect his own
daughter it says a lot about gore that
he isn't afraid of using other kids to
get her back and taika waititi is
clearly toying with themes about
encouraging children to be better people
than their parents that becomes even
clearer when thor agrees to look after
gore's daughter as the villain dies and
raises her as a hero thor's dad god
status is a huge change for the hero
going forward but it's such a central
element of the story in love and thunder
it's kind of amazing we don't even get a
whiff of it from the trailers
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the marvel cinematic universe are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one